bonsoir à tous nous sommes le mardi 17
mai merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
route cette nouvelle édition de 7,8 le
journal comme chaque jour nous revenons
sur votre actualité locale entouré de
nos invités les également des
journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite on commence avec les titres de
cette édition
l'entreprise solidaire d'électroménager
en vie existe depuis six ans à trappes
aujourd'hui sa réussite a été saluée par
odile kirchner délégué interministériel
à l'économie sociale et solidaire
elle s'est rendue dans les yvelines la
trappe ce matin pour découvrir
l'entreprise nous y étions la place cddp
inaugurait à voisins le bretonneux ce
samedi après un peu plus de deux mois de
travaux l'espace a été totalement
réhabilité et présenté au les sinois et
enfin premier épisode de notre série de
reportages consacrés aux yvelinois sur
la croisette à l'occasion du festival de
cannes en fin de journal et ce matin à
montigny le bretonneux la nouvelle
résidence du vélodrome pour jeunes
travailleurs a été inauguré le montant
de la réalisation de l'opération
réalisée par le bailleur osica s'élève à
12 millions huit cent quarante mille
euros avec la participation de l'état du
conseil régional et départemental mais
aussi de la caf
un bâtiment à l'architecturé
contemporaine comme vous pouvez le voir
sur les images qui comprend dix
logements accessibles aux personnes à
mobilité réduite les 183 logements
individuels de la résidence qui est
gérée par l'association pro logement des
jeunes travailleurs sont déjà pourvus
les précisions au micro de william el
est ce que je vois c'est que ça
fonctionne à 100 % le taux d'occupation
donc est à 100% il ya 183 places
il ya plus de 1000 demandes qui ont été
faites dont on voit bien qu'il y avait
un besoin
cinquante ans de vie le compte 145 mille
emplois de nombreuses entreprises dont
nous faisons le lien nous aujourd'hui
entre notre diversité de grandes écoles
nos jeunes du territoire
c'est une résidence qui s'adresse aux
jeunes travailleurs donc des jeunes de
18 à 26 ans à l'entrée des jeunes qui
sont en activité qui vont débuter une
activité professionnelle qui sont en
contrat d'apprentissage de
professionnalisation sur 2015 nous avons
accueilli nous avons traité plus de 1000
candidatures et nous avons accueilli 246
jeunes pour 183 places
le loyer est de 410 euros pour les
petites studette nous avons des studios
qui sont à 506 euros
le studio il est installé depuis six ans
attrape le magasin en vie spécialisée
dans l'électroménager d'occasion
solidaire est en plein développement
il embauche désormais 20 salariés en
contrat d'insertion
odile et cherche nerfs délégué
interministériel à l'économie sociale et
solidaire s'est rendu sur place ce matin
pour découvrir l'entreprise fanny
bourdillon assisté à la visite regardait
donner une seconde vie aux appareils
électroménagers se le credo du magasin
envie de trappes chaque année 1100
tonnes de déchets sont collectés dans
cet atelier on démonte on répare et on
remet à neuf
ensuite direction la boutique où les
appareils sont mis en vente à petit prix
et avec une garantie d'un an et ça
permet à toute une partie de la
population et à des consommateurs de
plus en plus soucieux d' démarche
environnementale de s'équiper à moindre
coût bien évidemment puisque
vendons ensuite ces matériels à avec un
coût bien inférieur au prix 9
ce mardi matin la déléguée
interministérielle à l'économie sociale
et solidaire a été invité à visiter
l'entreprise car en vie c'est aussi la
volonté d'agir pour l'emploi
l'entreprise lutte contre la précarité
et l'exclusion
objectif offrir un travail une formation
et un revenu aux trappistes les plus
éloignés de l'emploi
83% les personnes qui sont accueillis
ici ensuite débouche sur un cdd un cdi
ou une formation qualifiante
donc c'est une très belle réussite sur
cette capacité à réinsérer des personnes
dans l'emploi à ses débuts en 2012
envie embauché sept salariés en contrat
d'insertion aujourd'hui ils sont vingt à
pouvoir profiter d'un cdi contrat à
durée déterminée d'insertion les
contrats d'insertion sont des contrats à
durées courtes que l'on peut renouveler
pour une période de deux ans maximum
donc si c'est une rotation en fait de
deux personnels dès lors qu'elles sont
qu'ils sont formés ils retrouvent un
emploi dans les entreprises de la région
le groupe en vie existe depuis 30 ans
aujourd'hui 45 magasins sont implantés
en france
parmi les 2500 salariés deux mines sont
en contrat d'insertion et prenons à
présent la direction de
voisins-le-bretonneux vous la nouvelle
place des douves a été inauguré samedi
dernier après un peu plus de deux mois
de travaux la maire de la commune
alexandra rosati était fier de présenter
l'une des premières opérations de son
mandat levy ci doivent pouvoir profiter
de cet espace totalement réhabilitée
avec des places de parking
supplémentaires mais aussi un chemin
piétonnier william el est patrick
jacques de dixmude pour ce reportage
après dix semaines de travaux la place
des douves à voisins le bretonneux
affiche désormais un nouveau visage
un nouveau revêtement pour un espace
plus aéré que les vies si noah ont
inauguré samedi on en fait un événement
parce qu'on a vraiment mis beaucoup de
soin à la faire et à la variabilité et
parce qu'avant cette place était
vraiment très compliqué à utiliser parce
que des arbres qui étaient malades qui
n'était pas adapté je dirais la
dimension de la place un revêtement qui
incitait plus les habitants à venir
faire coter leurs chiens qu'à s'y
promener donc l'aspect de la place était
vraiment pas par attirant donc pour nous
c'est un événement est la place
proposent maintenant des stationnements
de parking supplémentaires en épi grâce
au revêtement l'entretien de l'espace
devrait coûter moins cher à la commune
c'est soit de l'art d'oise concasser
soit du gravillon donc forcément y'a pas
de bêchage particulier à faire et puis
les plantes aussi nous demande beaucoup
moins d'eau on est 7 heures des choses
qui demandent un entretien derrière
minimale est très belle et colorée par
rapport à avant et le sol et beaucoup de
plus
pratique pour marcher que qu'avant
c'était de la sorte de terre battue
c'est beaucoup mieux 20% de l'opération
a été financée par un fonds de concours
de saint quentin en yvelines
le reste est à la charge de la commune
pour un coût total de 300 mille euros et
nous allons parler culture à présent
nous avons parlé du festival les
artistes à l'école attrape enseigne
anciennement par bonds aux banlieusardes
pour cela nous accueillons en plateau ce
soir avec nous c'est si la fraise
vareilles bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation là vous êtes comédienne
metteur en scène et auteur de la
compagnie nike nda et vous participez
également à ce festival
tout à fait il me semble que c'est votre
deuxième participation vous avez déjà
vous travaillez l'année dernière avec
eux c'est ça l'année dernière nous avons
représenté le spectacle quand j'avais 5
ans je m'ai tué qui était un spectacle
en biffant talent dans des gradins qui
se font face l'un face à l'autre avec
des comédiens professionnels ça faisait
l'ouverture du festival
alors est ce que vous pouvez voilà
présenté peut-être brièvement deux ou
trois mots à votre compagnie votre
travail nous sommes une compagnie de
théâtre implantés en ile de france
particulièrement sur le val d'oise nous
travaillons en direction de la jeunesse
mais aussi de tout le monde
nous travaillons par la jeunesse pour la
jeunesse avec la jeunesse c'est aussi
pour ça que notre présence dans le cadre
du festival les artistes à l'école a
tout son sens alors donc c'est un
festival qui se déroule en attrapant
partenariat avec la salle de spectacle
donc de la merise qui est située à
trappes
quel son objectif c'est un petit peu
d'amener les enfants vers vers là en
fait tout à fait de leur permettent de
connaître et de côtoyer des univers
parfois différents qu'ils ne connaissent
pas et de s'approprier des codes et des
conventions de théâtre contemporain qui
sont pas du tout a priori les leurs donc
ces enfants qui n'ont pas accès
habituellement au théâtre alors pour
certains si on va pas à mettre tout le
monde dans le même panier pour d'autres
n'ont donc effectivement c'est une
véritable ouverture pour la plupart
quand même à des terrains inconnus sur
des auteurs contemporains pour la
jeunesse qui écrivit spécialement pour
eux et puis aussi sur des dramaturgies
contemporaines c'est à dire des manières
de raconter des histoires sur un plateau
de théâtre un peu différente que celle
qu'on peut voir habituellement
alors qu'on vous a redemandé
venir travailler pour ce festival vous
avez été tout de suite en partant avec
la compagnie oui parce que on trouve ça
très important en fait d'être à la fois
dans les lieux théâtraux et dans les
lieux de culture et en même temps dans
des lieux qui n'ont pas du tout accès à
la culture ou qui ne sont pas du tout
des théâtres donc on trouve ça très très
intéressant et important dans notre
démarche d'artiste d'être dans le réel
aussi et de côtoyer ce public réel est
de permettre avec avait que 2 de faire
un chemin ensemble et de se connaître un
peu mieux et de se rencontrer mieux et
connaître comprendre un peu mieux leurs
problématiques aussi skis ce qu'ils
pensent aujourd'hui en 2016 alors les
élèves qui participent donc à ce
festival sont de la primaire je sais que
parfois ou au lycée vous à travailler
avec une classe de lycée moi je
travaille avec une classe de collège
ce sont des 6e et à côté de ça je
travaille aussi avec huit volontaires
qui dépendent de plein d'autres classes
du collège
donc c'est un groupe un peu chamarré un
peu différent c'est pas seulement un
groupe class effectivement ma mission ça
a été de constituer un groupe pour
qu'ensemble ils puissent s'exprimer sur
scène alors votre spectacle s'appelle
tissage métissage et métamorphose dont
tire donc des métamorphoses d ovide que
vous nous en dire plus ce n'était
peut-être pas trop compliqué de parler
des métamorphoses d'ovidé comme voilà un
livre assez c'est compliqué qu'on étudie
d'abord au lycée à des élèves de collège
alors en fait les métamorphoses sont au
programme de sixième
donc c'est le professeur de français de
6e qui m'a demandé de plutôt axé sur sur
ce genre de deux textes
donc c'est un dialogue entre lui et moi
on s'est vraiment posé la question de
son désir de mes désirs à moi d'artistes
comment je crée moi je travaille
énormément sous forme de montage c'est à
dire que je pars pas uniquement d'un
seul texte j'aime bien aussi justement
tisser et métissée plusieurs auteurs qui
viennent à la fois l'antiquité qui sont
à la fois aujourd'hui dans le monde
contemporain
hélas ce que j'ai réalisé aussi avec les
enfants c'est une nouveauté
j'ai écrit avec eux donc il ya des
passages qui sont complètement écrit par
eux et je trouve ça assez fort justement
de leur visite des métamorphoses de vide
oui c'est une revisite notamment de la
métamorphose palace et arachne
arachne qui va faire qui va se
transformer en araignée est justement
qui va tisser sa toile et c'est un petit
peu une revisite de qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pour un être humain de tisser
sa toile d'être avec les autres et
d'être en lien avec les autres
différents ou alors c'est un spectacle
sur le fait de grandir ça c'est sûr le
fait de grandir c'est sur le fait de
grandir ensemble c'est sur le fait aussi
de se rendre compte qu'on fait partie
d'un univers vaste et démesurée mais qu'
on a notre place à avoir dans cet
univers et qu'on a surtout notre rôle à
jouer
alors concrètement vous allez commencer
à travailler que les élèves depuis mois
de janvier quand s'est déroulée la
pratique les ateliers pour arriver
jusqu'au spectacle donc qui aura lieu le
23 et le 24 mai donc à la mauvaise alors
il y à une alternance donc à la fois on
allait les voir dans leur établissement
dont il ya eu une des premières
rencontres où ils nous poser des
questions sur nos métiers sur ce qu'on
faisait dans la vie ça laisse à leur
paraissait des fois un peu étonnant que
ça soit notre métier
et puis il ya eu aussi une alternance
avec la merise ou ils sont venus voir
notre spectacle nos grands parents et
puis nous mêmes on leur a proposé un
spectacle impromptue dans leur classe
qui s'appelait pris en compte autour de
trois contes des frères grimm
donc ils ont pu découvrir plusieurs
phases de notre travail et plusieurs
moments de rencontre complètement
différente et différents les uns des
autres ces moments mais justement qu on
vraiment créer une belle rencontre une
belle alchimie entre nous sur
concrètement les élèves des enfants ça
leur apporte sa 7 e avenue et mais
j'espère le français la littérature vous
avez senti un engouement de ce côté là
je pense que oui c'est leur permettent
d'avoir accès à eux mêmes surtout et de
se dire qu'en fait ce répertoire
classique ou antiques et que ce
répertoire contemporain est fait pour
eux et leur donne une meilleure
connaissance du monde et de ce qui les
entoure et une meilleure compréhension
du monde et je suis épatée par aussi
leur leurs incursions leurs liens qui
peuvent faire eux mêmes avec leurs
propres connaissances notamment un
enfant sur les dinosaures qui connaît
tout des choses comme ça c'est assez
c'est assez joyeux et pour vous convie
théâtre c'est compliqué travail des
enfants avec des enfants ça ne nous
apporte plus ça vous fait aussi une
autre vie
on du théâtre ça apporte quelque chose
au spectacle alors c'est forcément un
aller retour c'est france forcément une
réciprocité c'est forcément parfois une
remise en question aussi parce que on
peut pas non plus attendre tous deux ils
peuvent pas attendre tout de nous donc
c'est des déplacements sans cesse les
uns vers les autres
et effectivement moi ça m'apporte
énormément d'ouverture et un nouveau
regard sur la jeunesse est sûr aussi
leur appréhension du monde et leur
appréhension dans le monde que ce soit
leurs peurs ou que ce soit aussi leurs
désirs leurs envies voilà donc
effectivement c'est une réciprocité
alors sans tout dévoiler du spectacle ou
presque pour se donner un avant goût est
ce que vous savez vraiment les enfants
qui vont être les acteurs dans ce cas ce
sont uniquement les enfants qui seront
sur scène et leur parole sera uniquement
tiré de leur propres mots des mots d'un
auteur contemporain qui s'appelle
sylvain levey des mots à moi aussi
puisque j'ai écrit et puis des mots
d'eau vides forcément l'idée c'est de
partir depuis la construction du monde
depuis le chaos depuis la pangée depuis
cet énorme continent qui s'est séparé en
six continents après qu'on connaît tous
un l'afrique l'europe l'australie
l'océanie je me mélange un peu les
pinceaux mais il ya aussi l'amérique
l'antarctique voilà et c'est un peu de
se rendre compte comment est-ce que tout
ceci la tectonique des plaques tout ceci
peut rentrer en lien les uns avec les
autres
l'idée c'est que
le spectacle va démarrer et tous les
comédiens ne seront pas sur scène mais
je n'en dis pas plus laissé le suspense
alors donc le festival les artistes à
l'école ça commence demain mercredi 18
mai à 19h donc il ya une représentation
de roméo juliette donc adapté de
shakespeare par les élèves de l'option
théâtre facultative du lycée de la
plaine du look d'une offre de trappes
donc votre spectacle le 23 et le 24 mai
donc toujours à la nourrice tissage de
métissage et métamorphoses dose de ville
et il y a voilà des représentations
jusqu'au 2 juin
merci beaucoup aimé ce si l'offre est ce
pareil donc je le rappelle le festival
c'est juste que ça commence demain et
c'est jusqu'au 2 juin
votre spectacle aura lieu le 23 et 24
mai 19h à la mairie de trappes et si
vous souhaitez plus d'informations
n'hésitez pas à voilà a demandé des
informations à la salle de spectacle la
merise merci beaucoup merci à vous un
mot de sport à présent et plus
précisément de football américain les
moins deux saisons les templiers
d'elancourt jouer ce week-end les quarts
de finale des play-off de fin de saison
contre les quarks les saint-quentinois
ont été terrassés par les essonniens sur
le score de 40 à 12 résumé du match
signés michela et demi d'euros et
william quelle grosse désillusion pour
les moins de 16 ans des templiers
d'elancourt les saint quentinois se sont
inclinés ce dimanche 40 à 12 en quart de
finale des play-off au complexe sportif
europe contre les quarks une équipe et
soutiennent la saison des élans courtois
est terminée on a fait beaucoup trop de
fautes pour pouvoir espérer gagner le
match et beaucoup de turnover de
l'interception d erreur d'alignement
débloque pas fait c'est beaucoup de
choses pour gagner un match sans
pression pour expliquer cette défaite
les cadres pointe le manque de rigueur
aux entraînements ces dernières semaines
il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont pas
venir entraînements et qui viennent au
match pour l'entraîner bafa les
dernières semaines d'entraînement
c'était pas du tout ça on n'avait pas
nos jours qu'il fallait il ya eu la
période de vacances c'est pas une excuse
les quartz racing leurs vacances mais
que pendant des semaines
pas l'effectif pourrait qu'on paie on
était des joueurs un peu partout pour
compléter les troncs c'est pas comme ça
qu'on prépare un match de cup relancer
cette saison la section u16 sera
reconduite l'année prochaine
les objectifs sont revus à la hausse
garder un maximum les joueurs garder
l'effectif qu'on a pas souvent prochaine
c'est de continuer pourquoi pas lors des
mouvements dans notre faim cette saison
la section des moins de 16 ans des
templiers d'elancourt comptait 35 15 15
il y avait également du football sur les
terrains de mort pas ce week-end en
tournoi international était organisée
sur les quatre terrains du stade du bout
des clots 60 équipes dont trois
formations belges et plus de 700 joueurs
âgés de 10 à 16 ans se sont affrontés
pour cette 21e édition
on écoute tout de suite il va voir que
le président de l'asmo repas et en
exactair il était au micro de willial
williams elle part dans ce dimanche
globalement on rencontre deux équipes
par rapport au championnat qu'on fait
tout au long de l'année et basse et
montrer son football et voilà havelaar
pour qu'on ait aussi aussi fort même
avec les équipes étrangères et de
montrer voilà que ben corps qu'on
pratique à mon football à maurepas et
deux équipes même proche un bois aussi
ce qui se passe c'est l'étranger parce
que le jeune et est totalement différent
et sport toujours du cyclisme sur piste
à présent les championnats régionaux
étaient organisées ce week-end sur la
piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une
cinquantaine de sportifs venus de toute
l'île de france a participé à
l'événement au programme du scratch de
la vitesse des courses aux points et du
crime on écoute le conseiller technique
régional d'ile-de-france francisco cause
aux micros des médias et demi d'euros il
ya tous les niveaux il ya des gens qui
sont qui se font plaisir ça va des
meilleurs amateurs élite aux meilleurs
juniors
et les meilleurs en fat régionaux et
départementaux tout le monde est
regroupé dans la même épreuve
les championnats régionaux sont quand
même les épreuves qui sont les épreuves
de référence qui nous servent à faire
les sélections pour les championnats de
france notamment les premiers
championnats de france qui auront lieu
en juillet à hyères championnat de
l'avenir on observe notamment les
juniors juniors cadets juniors et
parlons cinéma direction le sud de la
france où se déroule la 69e édition du
festival de cannes c'est notre série la
semaine chaque jour nous vous ferons
découvrir les évinois présents pour
l'événement rencontre aujourd'hui avec
l'acteur melvil poupaud 1re et melvil
poupaud pardon un réalisateur plaisir
oies et le jury du festival des juniors
2 des mureaux cannes à 7 8 7 avec alexis
garneau nicolas kirillovitch aigri le
week-end à l'est
jeannesson strass et paillettes et ses
mini star yvelinoise sur la croisette
clémentine eva anouk raysat à carla
kimberley yousra et jiangxi toutes les
huit sont scolarisés dans des collèges
et écoles de gargenville de vernouillet
et des mureaux elles ont eu la chance
cette année de venir à cannes à
l'occasion de la 15e édition du festival
des mesures faites au début c'était un
concours avec pleins pleins d'école
c'était dans les yvelines dont il y
avait plein de villes qui qui y
participer et
bah on devait faire un concours de
critique on devait voir un film et faire
un concours de critique et bah du coup
moi j'ai été prise enfin ma critique a
été retenu c'est la cerise sur le gâteau
elle attendait ça cette année jeudi elle
puisque nous avons un jury de filles
cette année elles sont toujours très
heureuse quand on arrive
oui c'est magique tout l'ambiance elles
ont adoré l'autre jour quand nous sommes
allés à la montée des marches
elles ont vu george clooney julia
roberts eva longoria voilà en plus on a
eu de la chance puisque c'étaient des
gens qu'elle connaissait
elles ne connaissent pas toujours
parfois de grands réalisateurs que nous
on connaît mais les découvre il ya
toujours une grande curiosité un grand
appétit de savoir des choses qui est
cette personne
comment ça se passe où on va qu'est ce
qu'on fait c'est un peu comme une
communauté
oui un ensemble de personnes qui se
réunissent pour regarder des films
discuter on allait au marineland sur la
croisette on a vu des stars en suisse
après midi peut-être qu'on va aller sur
des hits sur un bateau xterra et c'est
tout du rêve à la réalité c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune plaisir war
enfants déjà quentin dupuis était un
passionné de cinéma et depuis son bts
audiovisuel
il multiplie ses projets cela fait
plusieurs années maintenant qu'il vient
à cannes pour présenter ses courts
métrages au short film corner un espace
dédié aux courts métrages
la cinquième fois que j'ai à cames
première fois j'étais venu quand je
faisais mes études donc c'était plus en
mode pas touristes mais on découvre un
petit peu le festival
et là c'est la quatrième fois que je
viens plus en mode professionnel pour
les projets pour travailler et c'est
cette année on a encore un nouveau film
au short film corner et qui s'appelle
rencontre
c'est l'histoire toute simple d'un homme
et d'une femme tous les jours il assis
dans un parking voit une joggeuse qui
passe et décide à l'aborder ce qui joue
lamentablement à chaque fois mais du
coup cette fois ci la un allié assez
puissant il a le temps avec lui ce qu'il
arrive à remonter dans le temps à chaque
fois pour pouvoir essayer encore et
encore de voir parler à cette fille
sally
on se connaît et moftah par 06 et du
temps libre ce soir j'en peux plus des
mecs comme toi
vous croyez tout permis je ne sais pas
fin aux fans cette année en plus j'ai
plusieurs projets avec les canons on
revient sur les projets de long métrage
qu'on ne compte pas mal avancé on
continue à essayer de trouver des fonds
des producteurs pour monter ce projet là
j'ai aussi un projet qui s'appelle
classe et ans que je réalise avec un
restaurant américain qui s'appelle alan
3,6 et c'est une série de c'est un court
métrage en six parties en fait chacun
autour me réalise une partie de cet
épisode et du coup l'histoire se crée au
fur et à mesure se pressent comme une
imprégnation musicale en vidéo c'est à
dire quand j'ai fait deux premiers
épisodes
voilà ne savais pas ce que j'allais
faire et il a fait son deuxième eason en
réponse aux premiers mois j'ai fait le
troisième en réponse instituts et ainsi
de suite
et donc on continue on est vraiment
c'est un projet qui est en cours et ça
va continuer à sortir jusqu'au 11
septembre dans maman si je dis pas de
bêtises
enfin c'est notre star du jour c'est
melvil poupaud l'acteur originaire des
yvelines est à la fiche du film de
justin triais victoria aux côtés de
virginie efira et de vincent lacoste
un film présenté dans le cadre de la
semaine de la critique
c'est l'une des sections parallèles du
festival de cannes et victoria
l'histoire d'une avocate mère de famille
monoparentale amour sexe travail et
éducation tout s'entremêlent et
s'entrechoquent
alors le film c'est un portrait d'une
femme d'aujourd'hui c'est très
contemporain c'est virginie efira qui
essaye de gérer à la fois sa vie
professionnelle sa vie amoureuse et sa
vie de famille et qui ils sont tous là
ils se moquent de moi déjà moi c'est
pareil je vais très très mal merde mais
on est tu vas tout le temps mais elle
essaie de gérer sa vie c'est une très
belle femme très sexy et voilà et moi je
fais un type un peu allumé qu'elle doit
défendre lors d'un procès dans lequel on
m'accuse d'avoir agressé ma fiancée dit
toi une chose c'est que ta force c'est
ta beauté
c'est une blague non pour deux raisons
la première c'est qu'on peut pas
réellement croire qu'un beau même
voiture la deuxième c'est que
statistiquement les beaux gagnent plus
que le nez c'est pareil pour
l'intelligence tu vois les jurés ils
seront toujours plus indulgent avec un
type intelligent qu'avec un débile parce
qu'ils s'identifient 178 c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui
et n'oubliez pas comme le dit jean luc
godard quand on va au cinéma on lève la
tête quand on regarde la télévision la
baisse
un nouvel épisode de 15 ce sont 18 ce
sera donc demain dans le journal de
mercredi
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
tout de suite vous retrouver nicolas
kirillovitch ce pool 7,8 société il est
rentré de cannes a spécialement pour
vous ce soir thème du débat où en est
l'europe il en parlera avec ses invités
cher quand à moi je me retrouve demain
pour une nouvelle édition du journal je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée